- On this episode, I talk
about my favorite sneakers,
how I hustled a decade ago,
and VaynerMedia's holiday party.
You ask questions and I answer them.
(intro music)
This is the #AskGaryVee Show.
Hey everybody, this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and welcome to episode 52
of the #AskGaryVee Show.
Big day today here at VaynerMedia.
It is the holiday party.
I don't know who decided
to make this a Wednesday.
- [Steve] Thank you.
- Right? I mean...
Are you guys pumped for the holiday party?
- [in unison] Yeah!
- Thursday's gonna be a disaster.
(laughter)
Let's get into the show.
- [Voiceover] Harvest Funders asks
what does hustle look like for you now
versus five or even 10 years ago?
Why has it changed?
- This is such a great question.
Thanks Harvest for it.
And I'm gonna expand on it.
I'm gonna long form on,
I was even talking to DRock and Staphon
that this might have to turn into
a three to five minute video movie
because I'm starting to
have this weird realization.
I've been talking to Mike, Trainer Mike,
about this during the workouts
which is like, wait a minute.
Was I really hustling at 25 to 30?
I wasn't into email culture yet
nor was the wine industry nor was society.
The store closed at nine.
You know, after a while 7:30 felt like
the appropriate time to leave.
You know, I had girlfriends
that I lived with.
Brandon, my best friend
who runs Wine Library
lived above me.
And like, you know, I can
sit here and think about,
you know, 8:30 at night
on a Wednesday at 26
playing like Monopoly on GameCube
and that is just not even remotely close
in the equation at this point.
You know, it's really
fun to be a businessman
instead of an athlete because your prime
is so much further down the path
and you have so much
more time to get there.
Wait no, look athletes,
a lot of those people,
those kids are, you know, hustling
in Junior High and High School and so
maybe the timing's a
little bit different but,
you know, the truth is my hustle today
is at an all-time high
especially since June 7th
when I've incorporated working out
which has driven me to
wake up so much earlier.
Not that I have more energy
'cause I was high on sugar,
I've come to realize but,
I can tell you this.
Let's start with this.
Every person right here in this circle,
this inner circle of five
and anybody out there that really knows
and some of you have watched
and I've thrown up my
calendar here and there,
nobody comes close to me and really sniffs
my level of hustle and
how much work I put in
and don't take a step
back in saying, really?
Because it is literally
every second of every minute
of every day for a very
long period of time
and you hear about it,
Alex heard about it.
He was a fan.
He knew what I was spitting
through this, right.
He worked at VaynerMedia
but until he got a little
closer, it gets really intense.
It gets intense when I'm
working the way I'm working
and I'm texting 17 times on a
Saturday while I'm in the air
and saying do this, do
this and this, and this.
I'm gonna do this and
this and this and this
and this and this.
And so, my hustle is up.
- [Voiceover] Lyndon asks
in the first 30 seconds
of someone meeting you,
what do you reveal about yourself?
- Lyndon, this is a great question
and I'm gonna give you a great,
I'm declaring a great answer alert.
(trumpets blaring)
I can probably get somebody to
consume something from me
within the first 13 seconds
let alone 30 seconds because
it's not what I'm gonna say,
it's how I feel.
See, words are great but
energy's a whole different game
and I win on that game, right.
And so within the first 30 seconds,
I'm gonna establish and
have always established
from my entire life from first grade,
first 30 seconds in to
any business meeting
to when I'm in a big off site
when everybody goes around the room
and says, "I'm Staphon.
I work at VaynerMedia."
But then I do my, "I'm
Gary, I'm a Jets fan."
Like, I within 30 seconds, set the tone
vibe wise, if I don't get to say something
which is rare for me, not to say something
within the first 30 seconds.
I establish that I'm different.
Yeah, I'm different.
- [Voiceover] YaboyLV asks
what is your favorite pair
of sneakers of all time?
- That's a nice little segue
from the last question.
My favorite pair of sneakers hands down
is the 1985, I think,
Patrick Ewing Adidas.
I'm a huge Knicks fan.
Let me tell you my all-time
hated pairs of shoes.
Every single Air Jordans of all time
because I hate Michael Jordan.
And I love Patrick
Ewing and the 85 Adidas.
- [Voiceover] Mike asks, I've caught a few
of your #AskGaryVee shows
and love the content.
What are your thoughts on Google+?
Why do you continue to use it?
- Mike, I think Google+
is a failure for Google.
Once again, a big company that is amazing,
maybe, actually, my pick
for the best company
in tech in the world.
But, just doing something
outside of their DNA.
They try to copy something.
It was ill-fated in my opinion.
I still use it because there's
an audience of mine there.
It ties in nicely to the YouTube society.
There's a small niche group of people
that I massively respect from Google+
that are early adopters of technology,
early Twitter users and they've
created a nice community.
And much like every social
network besides Twitter,
most social networks are not so social.
They're content distribution
portals, unfortunately.
And I've got some audience there
and I will continue to
distribute my content
considering that it's so
native to the YouTube platform
where so much of this goes.
I mean, obviously people
listening on the podcast know.
I was talking to a bunch of people
that are listening to the podcast.
Hey podcast peeps, you know,
that how sometimes they go and run
and watch the show.
As a matter of fact, one of
our VaynerMedia employees
heard me say Asia and something else
and thought that I called you Asia
because they thought
that I was thinking India
and I said Asia and then
I punched them in the face
and said, "Do you really
think I wouldn't know that?"
Anyway, so they wanna watch
the video is my point.
My big point is, what I think about it is,
it's a loss but it still has value
and that's something that I want
everybody to pay attention to.
Nothing is ever dead.
I talk about email open rates being down
but email's probably at the
top of my marketing strategy.
It's not about 100 or
zero, it's where is it
at this moment.
And where Google+ is at this moment
is it still merits the
minimal time it takes
for me to post a YouTube
video on that platform
and occasionally engage
with that community.
Something that MySpace
no longer brings to me
but did in 2009 and 10
with Wine Library TV.
Get it?
- [Voiceover] Simplybeingmum asks,
are you a morning person?
- I am not a morning person.
I sleep like a brick.
Like, I mean, I literally believe that
somebody could break into my home,
stab me in the leg with a knife
and still then continue
to steal everything
out of my apartment.
I just sleep hard.
And so when I wake up,
it's just not great.
That being said, no
question, I'm waking up
a hell of a lot better
because of my working out.
A lot of times I've been talking about
how I haven't picked up energy
but what I have picked up
is the ability to wake up
on this five and half,
six hour kind of window
that I sleep, which I
know a lot of you think
I sleep three or four hours.
Heck, I'd sleep seven or eight
if I can really like, when and if I can...
By the way, and this is a
whole another long thing
that we gotta get into eventually,
it's not about how much you sleep.
It's what you do while you're awake.
So, a couple things for
the question of the day.
Obviously today is
VaynerMedia's holiday party.
Please tell me in the
question of the day, a story.
It's not a question.
It's story time, VaynerNation.
Tell me your most interesting story
from a corporate or company holiday party.
I need a little gossip in my life.
And number two, why
are you not visiting me
at the Wine Library on Saturday?
You keep asking questions.
I, get it, will keep answering them.
Don't forget to subscribe
to my YouTube channel.
(hip hop music)